und nun möchte ich mit boris palmer über
diese nacht sprechen er ist
oberbürgermeister von tübingen bei den
stuttgarter randalen wurde jetzt oft von
der partyszene gesprochen als
beschreibung der täter ist das in ihren
augen eine zutreffende beschreibung
beziehungsweise wie würden sie selber
die täter beschreiben
ich finde den begriff unglücklich den
ball partyszene da stelle ich mir doch
gute laune freundliche menschen und
irgendwie eine angenehme sommernacht vor
und wenn es auch noch stuttgarter
partyszene heißt dann doppelt ich glaube
der begriff wirkt verharmlosend das soll
nach solchen randalen nicht stehen
bleiben was gemeint ist ist ja
offensichtlich dass die menschen sich
dort getroffen haben um nachts party zu
machen und das in corona zeiten in denen
das eigentlich so nicht zulässig ist
sieht man auch an den fotos von abstand
und maske ist da nichts zu sehen
und ganz offensichtlich haben sich da
nicht alle schwaben und durchschnitts-
stuttgarter getroffen sondern eine ganz
bestimmte gruppe auch das kann man auf
den fotos erkennen den richtigen begriff
kann ich ihnen auch nicht sagen aber
partyszene das scheint mir nicht
treffend seit wochen wird über
polizeigewalt diskutiert nun es zu
gewalt gegen die polizei gekommen wie
hängen diese beiden themen ihren augen
zusammen
beides darf nicht sein
es gibt polizeigewalt die müssen wir
unterbinden es gibt sicherlich auch
rassistische polizisten den muss man
klar entgegen treten aber aus der
tatsache dass es das gibt bei der
polizei folgt natürlich nicht dass jede
kontrolle eines schwarzen drogendealers
schon rassistisch ist da spielt die
hautfarbe keine in der drogendealer ist
muss man die neben kontrollieren und
sondern auch festnehmen
beide debatten sind nötig wichtig wäre
es aber sie aufgeklärt zuführung nichts
mit den üblichen empörung ritualen und
immer das was man nicht sehen will
komplett von vornherein auszublenden
sondern genau hinzuschauen und deswegen
habe ich auch die fotos und die videos
von dieser krawallnacht und stuttgart
einfach mal angeschaut und auf mich
wirken lassen die stelle fest da sind
sehr viele menschen dabei die nur
gebrochen deutsch sprechen
die allahu akbar rufe von sich geben
die auf den ersten blick schon
migrations vordergrund haben und das
muss ich jetzt besorgen wenn bei
menschen die diese eigenschaften nach
außen zeigen wenn da eine solche
ablehnung unseres staates entstanden ist
was kann man dagegen ihrer meinung nach
tun
es gibt viele zugangsmöglichkeiten
präventiv ist natürlich integration der
beste schutz wenn die menschen das
gefühl hätten die polizei ist auf ihrer
seite würden sie nicht angreifen
wir müssen probleme bei der polizei
beseitigen wo es rassismus gibt muss man
dem entgegentreten glaube aber wir
müssen auch die frage klären wie der
über rassismus diskutieren
denn ich beobachte dass da eine
zuordnung von rechten und pflichten nach
der ethnischen zugehörigkeit stattfindet
das heißt also people of colour haben
sonderrechte müssen sich nichts sagen
lassen schon gar nicht von der polizei
in dieser denkweise weil sie eher
benachteiligt sind weil sie sind aber
daraus folgt eben nicht ein sonderrecht
und auf der anderen seite gibt es die
alten weisen männer die jetzt auch mal
benachteiligung erfahren müssen
und die bitteschön nicht einmal sich
nicht anmaßen sollen über etwas
mitzureden
wovon sie keine eigenen erfahrungen
machen können also da werden die
grundsätzlichen gleichheit und
gleichberechtigung im namen der
antidiskriminierung außer kraft gesetzt
dafür sollten wir uns hüten und ich
glaube dass das auch effekte hat dass
menschen die polizei irgendwann nicht
mehr akzeptieren wenn man davon ausgeht
jeder polizist ist sowieso ein
rassistischer gewalt tät und gehört auf
den müllhaufen
wie das in der tat geschrieben wurde
dann greift man eher mal zum
pflasterstein und wirft ein schaufenster
ein als den anweisungen der polizei
folge zu leisten
dieses gespräch mit boris palmer haben
wir bereits vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet